this new post or a world order  is just as dark if not darker than our  dystopian nightmares a lot of people and  our very very negligent media is going  to be telling you that this makes  abortion illegal all over the country  that is simply not what it does i am  angry  i i've never seen you so angry you seem  to be we have a right this big pretty  good american  for a commence  all this does is kick abortion back to  the state so it is no longer federally  mandated that it has to be legal totally  reasonable we have three branches of  government i know aoc doesn't know them  all yeah she missed in school if you  decide to just break down a branch  because it doesn't do what you want and  pack a court so you get more people who  just think the way you think then you're  not for democracy